Recall that congestion collapse occurs when packets
consume valuable network resources only to get dropped
later at a downstream link. And although the
network is forwarding packets, none of them actually
reach the destination and no useful communication
occurs, resulting in what we called congestion collapse.
We talked about congestion collapse in an earlier
lesson in this course. Recall that the goal
of TCP is to prevent congestion collapse. In this assignment, you will
become familiar with the Mininet environment,
creating custom network topologies, running programs in
virtual hosts that generate TCP traffic,
and learn about TCP congestion control, an
the TCP sawtooth. You'll also see how bandwidth is shared across multiple flows.
We are going to explore these concepts in a
particular topology that we'll just call a parking lot. So
in the assignment, you'll create the topology below with the following
parameters. N will be the number of receivers connected via
this switch like topology. The data rate of each link will be 100 megabits
per second and the delay of each link
will be one millisecond. Now your going to used
iperf to generate simultaneous TCP flows from each
of the senders. To the lone receiver. Then you
going to plot the time series of throughput versus
time for each of these senders. For each
of your experiments as you vary the value
of N. Your plot should run for 60 seconds.
We have given an initial file called parkinglot.py.
Your goal is to fill in the gaps.
You'll need to both fill in the part
that sets up the topology using a parameter of
N, and then you'll need to fill in
the part that actually generates the TCP flows
between the senders, and the receiver using Iperf,
and monitors the throughput of each of these flows.